The pandemic has already left businesses like Peter's up to 40 percent down.
There's going to be an impact as in there's going to be a cost involved.
And obviously and unfortunately, that cost is going to be handed on to the consumer.
Because obviously with the extra paperwork and the extra time at the ports.
I did vote for Brexit.
But, I think if I had my time again, I don't know.
Oh really? As serious as that?
Yeah.
Because of the impact on your business?
Because of the impact, yeah.
But, there's optimism here, too.
Steven's a fifth generation fish trader and says any problems are small fry.
Short term, there may be a couple of weeks where suppliers are maybe just a little bit nervous.
But long term, I'm very optimistic.
I believe it's a huge opportunity for this country as a whole.
I really do.